لقد تحدثت مع ماريا عبديفا،
مديرة الأبحاث في جمعية الخبراء الأوروبية
وسألتها عن
استهداف أوكرانيا المتزايد للبنية
التحتية والأراضي الروسية
إذا نظرنا إلى مدن مثل خاركيف أو
كارسون التي تقع على بعد 10 أميال من
الحدود الروسية، حيث
تهاجم روسيا هذه المدن.  من
الأراضي المحتلة أو من أراضي
روسيا نفسها كما لو أننا نأخذ خاركي
على سبيل المثال حيث يطلقون صواريخ S 300
من بلغارد لذا فإن الطريقة الوحيدة
لوقف ذلك لأنه لا توجد طريقة
يمكنك من خلالها اعتراض هذه الصواريخ هي
مهاجمة المحطات الموجودة على  أراضي
روسيا والهدف الآخر الآخر هو
قطع جذور طرق الإمداد الروسية
وأيضا
مستودعات الذخيرة الروسية التي تستخدمها
القوات الروسية لإعادة إمداد هجماتها
على أراضي أوكرانيا لذلك هذا
مشهد واحد والشيء الآخر  أن روسيا
تهدد دائمًا بأنها ستفعل
المزيد وأنها ستؤخر
الهجمات الأوكرانية، وهذا هراء لأن روسيا
استخدمت بالفعل جميع أنواع الأسلحة التي
استخدمتها ضد السكان المدنيين
في أوكرانيا، وقد رأينا
صورًا فظيعة فظيعة للمباني السكنية التي يتم تدميرها.
ضربت بالصواريخ الروسية أه منازل
دمرت مستشفيات مدنية أمومة
ما ضربته الصواريخ الروسية لذلك هذا
كل ما تفعله روسيا بالفعل
ولا يمكنهم فعل أي شيء أكثر فظاعة
وكما كنا نبلغنا فإن أوكرانيا
استهدفت للتو جسرين بين شبه جزيرة القرم و
المناطق المحتلة الروسية القريبة رأينا
هذا من قبل بالطبع ما هي
الاستراتيجية هنا وهل تنجح
الاستراتيجية هي قطع
طرق الإمداد للقوات الروسية في
الأراضي المحتلة من
مناطق باريس وأه دانيلز لأن روسيا
حولنا شبه جزيرة القرم إلى  القاعدة العسكرية التي هي
مشبعة بجميع أنواع
الأسلحة أه جميع أنواع القوات وهذه
هي طريقة إمداد القوات الروسية
لذلك هذا تكتيك أوكراني لقطع
طرق الإمداد وأيضا أوكرانيا
تستخدم الأسلحة عالية الدقة عالية
الدقة طويلة-  الصواريخ ذات المدى الذي تحصل عليه من
الشركاء الغربيين لضرب
مستودعات الذخيرة الروسية داخل شبه جزيرة القرم وكذلك
لإبطاء الهجمات الروسية
وإعطاء القوات الأوكرانية الفرصة
للمضي قدمًا
في الخارج